Nói chè quá hộ quan ngận nè của cân bảo khá máy gì,
philipeens lại tích tục phy đối mặt với sư bảo phượng hoàn,
với khả nân gệ người tao gió mạnh và ngập lũ chiến dọc
từ ngày 15.000.
Theo cơ quan khi tượng philipeens, bảo phượng hoàn dí chuyển điều rứng tây tế bắt,
tếng gần của bật đạo lúc dòng và VC-S,
và giữa báo sẽ đặt cấp sư bảo và chương mề mùng chiến nâng mề một.
Lượng mưa cực lớn nước tính toán là sẽ báo phủ mươi sáng tình,
tụi đạo lúc dòng, trong đó tụi đường mang lạ nằm trong cuộc kánh báo mơ mơ cam,
mất mùi em chỉ sau cấp đỏ,
cơ quan chương nàn tình báo báo của tình gây sống cao và sát lợn
ở các khu bực đối nũi làm thây đổi đẹh hình đường bởi biển.
Chương mừng đỏ mắt đình của cuối đạo và cực đợ báo,
chính quyền tức gọi người dân chủ đồng ngu ngon phó và theo dõi xác các bạn tin thử tiết,
tế bảo đảm át tàn.
Chuy đỏ báo khá máy gì càng quét tại philipeens,
khiến hơn bác chương người tịch mặt và mất em.